♪ You were already on the right track ♪
- Are you kidding? (booing)
(crew laughing)
- You can't boo every time
someone sings on this show.
Hey guys, it's Katie.
And this is another episode
of "Lost in Translation."`
As you know, we take a recipe,
we put it into Google Translate.
It goes from English to
Lithuanian to Aymara,
and many, many, many more.
And finally, back to English,
to give us a hilariously
translated recipe.
Today we have a super special episode
because we have Jasmine facing off
against our hilarious friend Tucker,
to see who can make the recipe
closest to the original.
Tucker loves games, he loves puzzles,
but he is a novice chef.
Jasmine may have the upper hand,
having so many of these under her belt,
but you never know what happens
on "Lost in Translation."
All right, let the battle begin!
- [Katie] Are you ready?
- I'm ready!
I can't wait.
- I was born almost ready.
- Three, two, one.
[Both] All kinds of hot bread!
- Something tells me there's gonna be
bread involved and
maybe it'll even be hot.
- I'm wearing the wrong shirt today!
I should have worn "I like
to butter my buns" today.
- What are you wearing today?
- I'm wearing "fruit juice mama."
We got new merch, everyone.
If you want some "Lost
in Translation" merch,
which was suggested by y'all,
make sure to check out the link
in the description below or right here.
shopbuzzfeed.com.
- I am very new to this, yes.
But cooking in general, as well.
- I think Tucker probably hates that
it's "all kinds of hot bread"
because it doesn't give him any context.
(crew laughing)
- All kinds of hot bread.
I don't know.
- You will be getting two clues.
- How many did Jasmine get?
- One.
- Oh baby, let's go.
I got a leg up already!
- Good luck Tucker. (laughs)
[Both] Step one.
- March nine large
seeds in the super bowl.
- Nine large seeds.
Seeds. Seeds.
- Super bowl. I'm gonna use
a big old bowl for this.
Lord knows why the word march is there,
but nine large seeds tells me
I'm gonna need nine of something.
- March nine large eggs!
Crack nine large eggs into a large bowl.
- Wait a minute. A seed.
Like maybe an egg?
An egg is a seed.
- Is it?
(Tucker laughs)
- I'm so indecisive, just as a human.
So I think that this is both
the best and worst possible show for me.
- I think seeds are eggs because science.
(laughing)
- I'm just gonna do nine eggs in this bowl
and we're going for it. Sure, why not?
Wow, we're crushing it, aren't we?
- I think it's eggs.
So now I'm gonna march nine
large seeds into my super bowl.
- We have our large-
Nine large seeds in the super bowl,
and I think march would be
whip it up.
So that's what I'm gonna do.
Directions number two.
- Add a pinch of salt and mix until
the pepper whites and onions are combined
and no pepper whites remain.
(Katie laughing)
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Add a pinch of salt, I can do that.
Salt, I think is salt.
- Okay. A pinch of salt.
I mean, in my personal language,
that would mean just add salt.
The pepper whites are
the whites of the egg
and the onions are the yoke of the egg.
Mixed that egg within an inch of its life
is what I'm hearing. Okay, here we go.
A pinch of salt. And we're mixing it
until those pepper whites
and onions are combined.
- Pinch of salt. Mix until
the pepper whites and onions are combined.
I think that means whisk until smooth
and no streaks of egg whites are seen.
But do I add pepper?
- Pepper, salt and pepper.
When you're making eggs,
you add salt and pepper.
Ooh, everyone calm down.
Everyone calm down. Pepper
whites, white pepper.
Okay, here we go.
We're adding some peppers
well, and you know what?
The word onion has to
be there for a reason.
- [Katie] So you don't think any
onions or pepper need to go in?
- Well, I just feel like if
onions were meant to be in here,
it would've told me the amount.
- Pepper whites and onions.
I'm thinking like an onion powder.
Couldn't be, couldn't be horrible.
Garlic powder. Maybe onion
powder is garlic powder.
A little garlic powder.
Look at that confidence.
Did you see me pick up the garlic powder
and put it right in there?
We're gonna stir until
no pepper whites remain.
- All right, this looks pretty good.
Step number three.
On a separate plate...
- I haven't even used a plate yet.
- Mix one and a half teaspoon bottle
with half cup water. Let it melt.
- I wanna let you know
that you only get one clue.
- I thought it was two?
- We are not part of this.
(Katie laughs)
- I demand justice in the comments!
Justice!
- Mixing makes me think bowl,
even though it says plate, I'm going bowl.
We're putting water in. Fantastic.
Is there a water source as well?
Oh yes, the sink, which we knew.
So I'm just gonna start with
what I know. Right off top.
One half cup of water. Here we go.
Okay, so that's one half cup water.
- Bottle. Container. Container.
Mmm. Liquid. Liquid. Oil.
Oil. Water.
But already have water. So not water.
- Bottle. Baby bottle. Milk?
Or maybe bottle is-
This is a bottle right here.
- How's Tucker doing on this stuff?
- Stop. No, I have to use a hint up top.
I'm gonna use a hint and I'm feeling
so confident about that.
I'm gonna use a hint. May
I take a hint from Kelly?
Okay. How's the hint
gonna be presented to me?
Rhyme it.
(laughing)
- This ingredient shares
its name with a drink
and you can also use
it to clean your sink.
- Whoa.
Bleach.
(laughing)
No, I'm kidding.
What do you clean your sink with?
Corn starch, I wouldn't drink that.
Baking powder. Baking...
Baking soda. Soda. I drink soda.
And baking soda you use
when you bake things...
right?
So we have the half cup of water.
We're mixing in one and a
half teaspoons in there.
- Bottle. Shots, shots,
shots, shots, shots, shots!
(laughing)
Bottles, bottles.
Soda bottle? Bottle cap?
Baking soda!
I think bottle is baking soda!
- How would I have ever gotten
there without that hint?
- Wow. Word association
really does come in clutch.
I would've never gotten
it if I didn't do that.
Shot, shot, shot, shot, shot.
- I think let it melt could
be, just mix it together.
If I just had the basic
knowledge of cooking,
I would be like, "Oh,
when you use baking soda,
you blah blah blah." But it's
like, I don't even have that.
So I feel like I'm at an unfair advantage.
- I'm doing one and a half
teaspoon of baking soda
and a half cup of water.
And now I let it melt.
- Okay, so step four.
- Beat the beaten box and
remove bubbles with a tell me.
- Beat the beaten box. Beat the eggs more?
- Maybe I use this?
- And remove bubbles with a tell me.
Huh?
(crew snickering)
What's a tell me?
I'm just gonna make sure that this
doesn't have any bubbles and we're...
That has more bubbles than
I've ever seen before.
- This is the only thing I've
made so far with bubbles.
And I think I need to remove the bubbles
by straining it. So that
is what I'm gonna do.
- A tell me is obviously a whisk.
If you know anything about
cooking, you'd know that.
I'm over this indecision.
We're going for it.
We're putting that in there.
We're beating the beaten box
and removing the bubbles.
It seems like the more I beat
it, the more bubbles happen.
- I don't think I've
actually ever had a recipe
to tell me to like, to remove
the bubbles from the egg.
- Do you think Tucker got this?
- For some reason, I feel like
Tucker's really nailing it.
- Okay. We're removing the bubbles.
It seems like the more I-
Oh boy. We're getting a
little dirty over here.
- Step number five. Through a fine sieve,
strain the potatoes into a bowl.
When they are alone.
Something has
(crew laughing)
not gone right.
- Okay, we're gonna
strain using the strainer.
No, we have potatoes down there.
Oh lord. What are you doing over here?
- Oh, combine this
and make it bubble?
- I think I'm confident about the eggs.
I'm just gonna strain
the potatoes into a bowl.
- I think I already did that.
When they're alone, set to the side.
- Is Jasmine going like,
so much faster than me?
Am I being annoying right now?
When they are alone. These
potatoes are alone right now.
Yeah, I'm gonna save this little
potato water, just in case.
You don't wanna get rid of
your potato water too soon.
Step six. Insert the parchment paper-
- Into the eight-inch panel.
- I mean step six is a game changer.
- Parchment paper is
either parchment paper,
wax paper or aluminum foil.
- That is (kisses) so chefs kiss easy.
Parchment paper. Got it.
Eight-inch panel. It's
gotta be just a pan?
- Panel.
Does that refer to a
cake tin? A square tin?
- Eight-inch panel.
Do we wanna make something circular
or do we wanna make something square?
Like this I'd be able to see
the side and see the layer.
I think we're just gonna go with that.
This, I'm like, you can't
put that in an oven, right?
It would melt.
- I'm gonna go with this red, square one.
Insert the parchment paper.
There is parchment paper.
- So that's the parchment
paper right there.
Should I cut it so it
looks a little nicer?
- Okay, I will cut this and
insert my parchment paper.
- So you're feeling really
confident about this?
- Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
- So we put the parchment
paper down in there.
Eight-inch panel,
parchment paper, let's go.
- This is good.
Step number seven.
- We're moving on to step seven.
- Pour the mixture into the prepared bowl.
Then cover with glue.
Make a small hole with a
toothpick. It has two holes.
What has happened?
Was I supposed to combine these?
- That we will do. Okay,
pour the mixture into the prepared bowls.
What is happening over here?
Which one is the mixture?
- I think I was supposed to combine these.
So what I'm gonna do is combine them.
- Yeah, I think the glue
is a clear food wrap.
And the toothpick, we just do a little
two stabs at the top
just to let it breathe.
We're not trying to
suffocate any potatoes here.
- I will now pour the mixture
into the prepared bowl.
- I feel like these two have
to be combined at one point.
Or do I want to save
the potatoes for later?
And who the hell knows
what we're doing with that?
Okay.
- Then cover with glue.
I think it's either more
parchment, or Saran.
- We're gonna be baking, or something.
We're putting that in there.
I'm just gonna cover it
without the potatoes yet.
The potatoes are off to the side.
Okay, this is the prepared
mixture in the eight-inch bowl.
- My glue is Saran wrap.
- [Tucker] Part of the challenge
is just getting this off of here.
Okay, there we go.
And we're poking it with
a couple toothpicks.
Scoobidy boop, scoobidy boop.
- All right, yeah baby!
I'm gonna make two holes
with the toothpick.
- Okay, we're moving on.
- Step number eight.
- Fill a large pot one
third full with water
and put the steamer on high ground.
- I think this means to fill a large pot
a third of the way with water and
add a steamer over high heat.
- Couldn't be more clear.
- I feel pretty okay!
- Let's just examine our
heating surfaces right now.
- Look, a steamer! I mean
I guess it is a large pot.
- A third with water.
This thing is quite the contraption.
- [Katie] A pot?
- That's a pot! That's a
pot if I've ever seen one!
We're going to the sink. And
put the steamer on high ground.
Steamer. What am I doing?
This is a steamer!
- I have filled my large pot
a third of the way with water.
The steamer is on high ground,
which I did over a high
heat and it is now boiling.
- I'm gonna bring this to a boil
and then what I'm putting
inside only God knows.
- So let's move on to the next step.
- Step nine.
- We take the bread and eat it.
- Cook for 10 minutes until tender.
- I don't understand.
- Now starting to think
that I should have combined
the potatoes with this because like,
you'll want to cook the
potatoes and the egg.
- Am I steaming some bread?
- Which one is the bread?
- Am I steaming that?
- Like what, do I put this inside
for 10 minutes and steam it?
- I think I need a hint.
- [Katie] Do you wanna
use your one hint here?
- Hint!
Katie, and I want you to...
(crew celebrating)
sing it!!
♪ You were already on the right track ♪
- Are you kidding? (booing)
- You can't boo every time
someone sings on the show.
♪ That water, that water ♪
(Jasmine booing)
- I guess I was on the right track.
I'm gonna be adding my eight-inch
panel to my steamer here.
I have a feeling Tucker
honestly won't even need hints.
- Okay, I think that I need a hint
and I'd love it from Mimo.
Here we go. Here we go.
Get your Meryl Streep on, Mimo!
(laughing)
(snickering)
- I'm thinking we gotta
put the potatoes inside
because we have to cook both
the eggs and the potatoes.
(laughing)
- Don't look at him!
- She went.
She like, started to nod or shake head
and then turned it into a full circle
just so I had no idea what she meant.
At this point in time, I no longer care
when, who, how they're cooked.
I just wanna make sure
this thing is cooked, okay?
So we're adding the potatoes in.
At the end of the day, we just
wanna make this edible okay?
So we're putting that in there.
Okay, 10 minutes on the clock.
- It's been 10 minutes.
It looks good.
- So this has been cooking a
little longer than 10 minutes.
Begs the question, did
it take longer because
I wasn't supposed to add the potatoes?
Oh, we did it! Okay.
I think I'm on the right path.
I think Jasmine's looks identical to this
and I think the final result
looks incredibly similar to this.
- Step number 10.
- It will be very cold, then
shape into one-inch balls.
- Remove and chill.
So I think it will be very cold
means take it out and let it cool.
- Maybe that just means
like pop it in the fridge
or freezer because it's gotta cool down.
- If I'm losing my mind,
Tucker's probably losing his mind too.
- So we're gonna put it in a freezer.
- I think I'm gonna put
this in the fridge first
and then we'll shape
them into one-inch balls.
- Okay, this is looking mighty cold.
- It is now very cold.
- Let's move on to the
second part of step 10.
- Shape into one-inch balls.
- One-inch balls. Oh, what is this?
A melon baller. We're just
gonna scoop and plate.
Scoop and plate. That
can't possibly be right.
- So I'm gonna cut these
into one-inch cubes.
- I mean we gotta take it outta there.
- I'm gonna flip this.
I'm not a fan of the color.
It's gray from oxidization, I suppose.
- What does one-inch
balls mean? Oh my gosh!
We're just gonna cut and
we're cutting it like a pie.
So we're gonna move on to the next step.
One-inch balls, I say no to that.
Step 11.
- Heater, one of sesame
oil over high heat.
Add the chicken yolk
and cook until browned
on both sides, five minutes total.
- And to think that I was doing so well.
- Oh okay, so I think I'm gonna be
heating up some oil over high heat.
- We're bringing back the pan.
- I think my chicken yolk is my egg,
but if it's over high heat,
it can't be sesame oil
because that's usually a finishing oil.
So not sesame oil.
Both sides makes me feel better
because I didn't ball it.
Balls have no sides. Science!
- You think Tucker's
putting this together?
- Probably. Tucker's so smart.
- A sphere doesn't have
more than one side.
So what's both sides mean?
All I know is that we have
to add one sesame oil.
- I'll go with olive
oil. Let me heat this up.
Now I'm gonna add in my chicken yolks
and I am gonna brown them on
both sides about five minutes.
- So we are going to slide this in there.
That's not moving the
way I thought it would.
We're just gonna put in these.
Both sides means that I have to somehow
flip this, which will be fun.
- While this is cooking, I'm
gonna move on to the next step.
- Step 12. Meanwhile, combined
in a bowl, small bowl.
- Half teaspoon paprika, half
teaspoon white sesame seeds.
- Fourth teaspoon garlic powder,
one fourth teaspoon ground cumin.
- Quarter teaspoon dried garlic,
quarter teaspoon red pepper,
quarter teaspoon smoked paprika.
- And one fourth teaspoon salco.
- Small bowl.
- In a small bowl.
[Both] We have so many ingredients here
that we're working with
and all of them are, to me,
English words that make sense.
- Wait, let me just check on these.
I don't want it to...
- Definitely time to flip.
So I'm coming back to that.
- Cute! The color is getting better.
- It's bubbling in a way I don't like.
- Smells good.
- You know what?
I don't care how you think this looks.
This is about to taste good
with all this seasoning.
- Half teaspoon paprika. I
do think paprika is paprika.
- Half teaspoon of paprika.
- Half teaspoon white sesame
seeds, which are here.
Let's go with white sesame seed.
- One half teaspoon white
sesame, white sesame.
So we're gonna do half
teaspoon of white sesame.
- Next, we have quarter
teaspoon garlic powder.
I'm gonna do garlic powder.
- One fourth garlic powder,
one fourth teaspoon garlic powder.
- Quarter teaspoon ground
cumin. I do think it's cumin.
- Ground cumin. I don't think
I know what cumin is really.
- Quarter teaspoon dried garlic.
I think that's minced onion.
- Garlic powder. Wait, I just
did that. We'll come back.
- Quarter teaspoon red pepper
is quarter teaspoon cayenne.
- Not like red pepper flakes?
- No.
- Red pepper is just
red pepper flakes. So we're
just gonna do a little of that.
- Quarter teaspoon smoked paprika.
But I already put in paprika.
I'm gonna go with another
quarter teaspoon of paprika.
(laughing)
- Half teaspoon of smoked paprika.
- You put paprika in already and
then you put more paprika,
but smoked paprika?
- We didn't catch that did we?
- A quarter teaspoon of salco,
which I think is salt.
- Salco, salco, salco, salco.
Salt. So I think salco is salt and pepper
'cause sal, salt, and
the co is kind of just
when you say it really fast.
Salt and pepper. Salco.
- The thing is, I lost my
confidence a while ago,
so now I'm just kind of rolling with it.
- Step 13.
- Add the onion mix mix
and cook for another minute.
- This isn't onion mix.
Did we have any form of onion in there?
- Dang, onion mix mix?
I feel like I have to coat it all first
and throw it back in there.
So I'm gonna take my eggs,
adding in my onion mix mix.
Giving it a good toss.
I'm gonna add everything back into my pan
and cook for another minute.
- But this is obviously,
this has to go inside, right?
So we're gonna sprinkle this on top.
Cook for another minute.
So I'm gonna add a little more oil
'cause I don't want the bottom to burn.
- Right now, Tucker's
probably looks amazing
or really chaotic.
- Now look at that, kind
of moving around here.
- Last up.
[Both] It is easy!
- Nana!
- They did say it is easy,
which I beg to differ.
- It was pretty hard.
- Serve it up
and hope Nana lives
through to see another day.
- It is easy. Transfer
to plates. Ta-da! Nana!
- Final thoughts.
Everything is cooked and
so for that, I am blessed.
- Tucker!
- Hello!
How are you?
- Much shorter than you. How about you?
It was very rough.
- It was rough.
- Maybe for the both of us,
but I'm excited to see what you made.
- I'm so excited. I wonder
if they look similar or not.
- [Katie] Open your eyes.
(laughing)
- That looks incredible!
- That looks incredible too!
So clearly we have all
kinds of hot bread here.
I am excited to see the original dish.
Shall we bring it out?
- Let's bring it out.
- [Katie] Open your eyes.
- Oh wow!
- Damn!
Jasmine!
- Wow.
I am not gonna lie. I'm very shocked.
So what is this dish?
- [Katie] Based on a viral recipe
that they found on TikTok.
We're calling it "viral
Chinese steamed eggs."
- I'm dying to try. Is
that allowed in this?
- [Jasmine] Absolutely. All right,
let's give it a try.
- Okay, let's go for it.
[Both] Cheers!
- Mm!
- You are lying to everyone.
(laughing)
It's not horrible.
- Literally, it's eggs and potatoes.
It's really good. Do you wanna try mine?
- Thank you. I would be honored.
- Cheers!
- Bite-sized, thank you.
- It's a seasoned time, it's good!
- It is beautiful.
- All right, let's give this one a try.
[Both] Cheers.
Mm, that's really good.
- That's really good, but
you're not far off at all.
- I think we did good.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thank you again, Tucker, for being here.
- Thank you so much for having me!
- And if you wanna check out
some "Lost in Translation"
merch, check out shopbuzzfeed.com
and tune in next week for more surprises.
[All] Bye!
- Should we do a little glam shots?
Don't get too close with the glam shots.
I think you need to try Jasmine's.
- Do we need to?
(laughing)
- [Jasmine] Mimo, eat it!
- I really like the potatoes!
- [Tucker] Thank you!
- Bottle of service. Bottle service!
- Let me just tell everyone
I have an over 200-day
Duoingo streak, okay?
So I think I know how to translate things.
(laughter)